The following is a production of Frank De Freitas and the Internet Red Zeum of Holography.
Hello, everyone, this is Frankie Freitas, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
Now on our second show of this season, the 9899 season.
Our guest this week is Bill Freed, and Bill is a virtual partner with the Iacoka Institute and also the owner and director of Freedlance Consulting.
And we're going to be talking with Bill on a topic that many of us should be concerned about.
And that topic is students who are not choosing to go into fields of science and technology.
And Bill's going to come on and try and give us a little bit of insight into the reasons why students are not choosing the fields of science and technology as careers.
A little bit later in the show.
First, I have uh a little bit of news here.
I got an email email, excuse me, from Derek Gallon, who is with the Royal Holographic Art Gallery.
And Derek has available film, which is uh very similar now to AGFA's materials.
It says uh here some time ago when introducing our first Red Star holographic film, we expressed our hopes to introduce soon a new film that would be closer to AGFA standards.
And they go on to say this is with extreme pleasure that we can now inform you that this film is already available now.
We thank you for your patience, and we are sure that you will find this new generation of film much improved and to your full satisfaction.
Unlike our standard Red Star film, this one can be developed with formulas normally used for Ag Fa, and the exposure times are better than HoloTest.
So it's uh film's named Red Star Ultra.
Here's a few tech specs.
Uh resolution over three thousand lines per millimeter, light sensitivity eighty to 100 microjoules.
Uh diffraction effectiveness, over 40% can be achieved.
Emulsion thickness, seven microns, and the acetate base thickness is 140 microns.
This film can be used for both reflection and transmission holograms.
And chemicals used for Ag for HoloTest 8075 work fine on this material.
There's also a Red Star Ultra G, which is green sensitive as well.
Sensitivity range of 488 to 532 nanometers.
Perfect choice for argon and pulse Yag, of course, for reflection and transmission holograms, and the same chemicals that are used for Ag for Holotest 856.
This film is available for ordering now.
And here's a couple prices in US dollars for 4x5 film sheets, 50 pieces for $92.
8 by 10 film sheets, 50 pieces for $310.
And 14 inch by 34 foot rolls, a single roll is 495.
These prices are effective August 98.
Initial sizes and prices.
They will do custom orders as well.
And if you want more information, you can visit Royal Holographic Art Gallery.
Here's the web address.
HTTP colon slash slash dub dub dub dot holograms.bc dot C A.
Or if you go to any search engine, I'm sure if you type in Ro Royal Holographic Art Gallery, the Derrick's site will come up.
And if you're an amateur uh hobbyist or even professional holographer, uh you may want to look into this film.
I know I'm going to look into it because I for so many years I got so used to using AGFA and uh I just couldn't get the hang of using anything else when AGFA closed its uh manufacturing facilities.
And I'm very happy to hear that the same chemistry can be used as well because I pretty much had that down pat as far as exposure times, chemical processing uh uh temperature and so on and so forth.
So that's the news for this week.
It's good news for anybody who's doing holography, uh, check out that film.
They also have plates available as well, which I don't know if I mentioned that or not, but I will mention it now just in case I didn't.
Our guest this week, Bill Freed, is going to speak with us about why students are not choosing science and technology careers.
And this is something that's going to give us a problem sometime in the future.
Um so what I will do is I will say my goodbyes now.
If you're tuned in, thank you very much for tuning in.
Remember, HoloTalk comes your way every week with a new topic and guests uh mostly centering around the field of lasers and holography.
But we also go off on little uh directions here and there, sometimes on uh little fringe type of uh programs as well, but all centered around science and technology topics.
So thank you very much for tuning in.
I'm going to turn the show over to the interview with Bill Freed that we did earlier in the week.
Bill is uh calling in from Waco, Texas, and I will not come back on after the interview's over, so I will say goodbye to you now.
And uh once again, thank you for tuning in to Hall of Talk and look forward to providing a great season of shows for you.
This is the second show of this season.
We've got a lot to go before we get back to our summer reruns again in nineteen ninety-nine.
This is Frankie Fratis, take care and thanks for tuning in.
Well, this is Frankie Frasen, we've got Bill Freed on the line who's in Waco, Texas right now and Bill is a virtual partner of the ICO Institute and Director of Freedlance Consulting.
And Bill, if you could tell us um what freedlance consulting takes care of.
Well hi Frank and I'd be happy to.
Freelance is about ideas, innovation and application in career and workforce development systems building.
And we work to try to help our clients in their efforts to design systems for the careers and workforce of the future.
Mm-hmm.
Are there more or less students going into careers in science and technology than there were, say, 10, 20, even thirty years ago.
Well Frank, um overall these figures are being reported um, you know, is much lower than in the past.
And certain groups like the Information Technology Association of America and the US Department of Commerce predict uh major shortages actually in students pursuing careers in science and technology.
And in a recent report of theirs entitled America's New Deficit the Shortage of Information Technology Jobs.
It was reported that approximately 300,000 information technology jobs will go unfilled in the next few years and by the turn of the century nearly one million vacancies will be open.
And while many people argue these numbers, us in the field of workforce development and c career development can't help but see the active efforts of such companies as Microsoft um and others to address the shortage and make every visible or very visible efforts to attract more youth to IT careers.
Information technologies.
Yes, specifically in information technology.
And um a good example is they recently released a video um with starring Jimmy Schmidt's um you might recognize that name from NYPD Blue.
Yeah.
Um in the video, the idea of the video was to um make people aware of all of the great opportunities in in technology and information technology careers and um get it out to the schools.
We're we're surrounded with technology everywhere we go, whether we're in our car traveling or we're sitting at home surfing the web or even television with the digital delivery with satellite uh dishes that we're getting our TV programming and fiber optic delivery of information.
Well, why now of all times when we're entering an age when we have a burst of technology that just surrounds us in the home and surrounds us in the workplace, why now are are kids not going into this?
Well that uh that's a good question and there's been a lot of work done to go in and conduct focus groups with schools, talk to educators, talk to parents, um and specifically look into why kids are not pursuing these high demand jobs.
As you said, um a good example is we all drive cars.
Um whether you work on those cars, you sell those cars, you service those cars, um, even at the gas station, you're dealing with technology, um you use the automatic uh gas cards now to pay for your gas.
Right through the gas pump, uh almost a um Mac machine of sorts.
And some of these efforts to find out why um or what factors contribute to this deficit.
Uh one of one of them was a a typical image of kids stereotyping persons that work in technology as um in a negative image as uh a you know white uh balding middle aged man with a pocket protector um you know a computer geek uh basically and and they were this image doesn't appeal to kids.
It just you know and and and that's unfortunate and um you know that's something that the education system needs to address, parents need to address and uh it's it's all it all has to do with the preparation and the system um that we have uh good or bad um needs to address uh what careers are hot basically and get people in um you know very interested in them and uh and basically uh what what's happening now is a lot of companies are investing in ways to market those occupations because if they don't have the workers of the future um they're not gonna be able to function.
And of course that stereotypical image that we get from Hollywood thrown at us all the time of your typical science or technology geek that's there's nothing to be further from the truth, right?
That's right.
Without a doubt.
I mean, those are some of the most exciting careers.
Um uh anybody that you deal with that works out in the Silicon Valley, they absolutely love their job.
It's dynamic, you're on the cutting edge, um, you're experimenting as you said, um, we're on the frontier of so many things in technology that um no matter what your skills, interests, aptitudes or talents are, um, in information technology jobs, you would have plenty of opportunities to exercise those skills, pursue interests, um, you work with a lot of people, uh, it just draws on a lot of talents and and skills and abilities.
When do you think we we will feel the effect?
I imagine this is going to have some sort of an effect on us, the fact that there's not going to be enough workers to fill the positions, but there's probably people who are listening to this show right now who have been left go because of companies downsizing and eliminating some positions who would find it really hard to believe that we're going to have a surplus of jobs in the near future.
W when do you think all this is going to have an effect on us?
Is it is it two years down the road, five, ten, twenty?
Mm-hmm.
Well I'll tell you, Frank, right now, um the United States is the world leader in a lot of uh the technology applications, um, software, hardware, um, and there is uh continuing concern that our competitive advantage in this country will be lost because we are not building the system and the supply chain of workers for these jobs in the future.
And at present, many industries report, not just in information technology, but in uh many science careers, advanced manufacturing, um, that are using new applications in traditional jobs that unfortunately are all pretty much um stereotyped as uh you know one negative type of a stereotype or another where um people think that like in manufacturing it's a dirty job where they it's noisy and whatnot and somebody's in the industrial revolution view of the s what shop.
Correct.
Yeah, which really isn't true anymore.
No, not at all.
I mean I'm in uh manufacturing plants all the time and it's all computer driven.
It's completely computer driven.
Um, you know, in the in the uh semiconductor industry there's a huge shortage and the companies have invested tremendous resources to prepare people for these jobs in the future.
And the example is information technology.
Um they're saying that um shortly in the new century the number the amount of openings and the skills um deficits of current workers that might want to even apply for those jobs are gonna be critical.
There will be an o over a million jobs um unfilled in information technology.
I would imagine someone who would go into manufacturing today would be more than likely to walk into a clean room environment than they would a shop floor.
Is that true?
Oh I would think so, yes.
I mean there's sure there are still some traditional manufacturing shops but um now with the with the use of robotics, with the with the use of the automation, uh many of the the jobs now require um, you know, not so much just the uh mechanical aptitude of the past where you might be, you know, moving a widget from here to there or attaching something to it.
Um, you're more of a systems player looking at how the whole the whole process, the whole line flows, um, monitoring equipment, doing quality assurance, um, dealing with customers.
That's something that we hear more often um now in the in the workforce development field is that uh production workers and manufacturing plants, when they're working with customers, the customers want to see the products being made.
They want to talk to the workers.
Um they wanna, you know, get a feel for who it is that they're buying from.
And uh more more than ever, they need to draw in all these diverse talents, um, in the in almost all manufacturing settings.
And that and that data is consistent.
Um, you know, a lot of what's being done now is using really technology tools to better connect job seekers with employers that are hiring.
And the skill sets that uh are being required are just getting more advanced, drawing on more personal, interpersonal resource information types of skills.
So that we're not um you know, going into a job anymore and and checking our brains at the door and just working, um, you know, in w in a repeat process, just doing the same thing over and over.
Now you have to understand how your role fits into the bigger picture and uh defect the product going down the line, um how that's gonna affect the customer at the end, affect profits back to the company and affect uh, you know, your future basically.
So, um, you know, the the the jobs are becoming more demanding.
Um, you know, employers are looking for people with those types of skill sets that can see the whole picture, that can help them make profit, um, so that they can in turn um share that profit in in an ideal sense.
Well it's obvious that we need to roll up our sleeves and do something about this, but uh let me just hit you with like a two part question.
Number one, who needs to do something about it that will allow more students to have an interest in this and what is it that these people need to do.
Well, uh that that's a good question.
Who needs to do something about it?
Um, everybody.
Uh parents especially.
Uh really career development starts at home.
Mm-hmm.
And if um you all hear all the time, uh you ought to be a basic parenting class, um before somebody's allowed to have a child.
Uh I was like that.
Yeah, we're a young person who suggested that.
That's you personally though, of course.
But um there's a lot parents can do themselves to to make their kids aware of you know, what what are their um aptitudes and and help them develop interests and explore different things.
Um, you know, m get them to start thinking, um, you know, at an early age and to um experience different things, um and to, you know, see how that they can apply knowledge and and solve problems.
Um so career development i i is just that.
It's a developmental process that starts from birth, you know, when you figure out your interests, um, you know, what your likes and dislikes are.
Um parents can really help to promote that.
Um and it in It's probably something the parents wouldn't even think about until the child's probably either either in late middle school or early high school, but actually the process should begin a lot earlier than that.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I mean uh how often do you hear a kid that's fourteen and the first time they're being asked what are they gonna do is you know when they're in uh high school and they have to make a choice between um an academic track or a general track or you know some type of a vocational track in school and there's just more options than that and they need to be thinking about that earlier.
So you know y you're seeing an increase now in um efforts to get the kids and to help expose them.
Um a lot of work is going on in in something called school to work and and school to work is an effort that tries to get people from the world of work into the schools and get the schools into the world of work and expose kids at an early age to careers.
And I was at a conference about probably about five years ago and there was a small school in West Virginia and the kids put on a play and um each kid played a different role like he was a lawyer, he was a doctor and it was really centered around having the kids understand and apply um things that they thought about um from those professions.
Even those simple types of things at least get kids to start to understand uh what all these jobs are out there.
Um and I have a question for you Frank.
Can you tell me how many different occupations there are more than one.
More than one.
Very very safe.
Well th there's a there's a question, Dom and and um during summer programs we used to ask high school kids that question.
And uh vocational maturity is a concept where um you or I, uh depending on our age level, you know, are exhibiting appropriate vocational behavior.
And uh usually you're looking for a questi the answer to be somewhere around um uh twenty to fifty thousand 'cause there are actually thirty six thousand different occupations um and you know, every day more are being added because technology is changing so fast.
Over thirty-six thousand over thirty six thousand occupations are available.
Mm-hmm.
And again, you know, that that number increases every day and and uh good quote I heard was the former Secretary of Labor at a workshop said that by the time youth enter ninth grade, um they're preparing for jobs that haven't even been invented yet.
Yeah.
So by the time they get out of school, you know, they'll the the entire skill set um is gonna be upgraded.
There's gonna be uh, you know, a whole new set of occupations available to them and you see it every day.
So it makes it makes the job of professionals, of teachers, of parents all that more daunting to help uh, you know, kids understand.
Well the resources are there.
Um I imagine the web must be filled with career information.
Yeah, the web has a lot of good information and there are a lot of excellent sites on um you could anybody could go to uh W W dot U S D O L E T A, which is the US Department of Labor Employment and Training Administration site.
Yes.
Um America's Job Bank is there, America's Talent Bank, um, where anybody can post a resume there and then any employer in the country or actually in the world could um uh you know, do a key word search and see if people are out there that need a skill set that they need.
Um there are, you know, all kinds of sites out there now you can um go into to uh assess your aptitudes, your interests and really help you make decisions.
And um, you know, the guidance counselors at schools and teachers, um, you know, they're excellent resources.
Uh and um a big effort now in in the United States in this country is something called one stop.
Um and in the past a lot of these types of services were only available to certain target populations.
But legislation that has just been passed, um, the workforce investment act of nineteen ninety eight that's basically gonna swing these doors open to the entire community.
So anybody can come in and access the latest and greatest in computer um assisted job search tools, computer um assisted aptitude tools, uh, you know, career resource libraries and really talk to knowledgeable people who know what's hot and what's not in specific regions.
Mm-hmm.
Those are a few um efforts and um, you know, people can be creative and just uh pick up the phone and uh call a company where they'd like to work and say, I would like to come in and find out what you do.
Um, you know, I'm uh doing some career exploration and and I would bet nine times out of ten, um, you know, people are willing to see people that are interested in their career field.
I bet that's something that a lot of people would never consider picking up the phone.
Yeah, I mean that's that's a great simple tool and it doesn't cost anything.
Um, you know, and i and employers they could help out by, you know, taking those calls and and helping uh kids or even adults that are going through retraining, um, find out a little more.
And then community colleges are an excellent resource as well, um, where people can um find out about a whole series of careers.
So there are a lot of resources out there.
Universities, colleges, high schools, parents, businesses themselves, public resources, the library.
Uh most libraries now have um you know a whole subsection just on careers.
Mm-hmm.
And um, you know, those are those are just some uh off the top of my head tips.
But uh it boils down to a three-part process, Frank, and uh that's what we always try to help in in building systems for regions or um building systems for big national programs is uh, you know, there's three parts to it.
You know, there's yourself and knowing yourself, um, knowing the market, which is the labor market, and making the match.
And in a nutshell, um, you know, there's a lot of processes in each of those that can tap into technology um uh in using, you know, management by fact that will help people find out what are uh the occupations of the future such as those that uh utilize science and technology.
Yeah.
Well it seems to me that the big challenge is to at least make this career choice something that kids would be really excited to make.
I'd really like to do that, and that seems to be where the stumbling block is right now because most people just think that it's some geek job that uh wouldn't be cool to go into when actually there couldn't be anything further from the truth.
You've got that rate.
Alright, Bill, thank you very much for being on Hall Talk.
And I'll give some information about your website uh towards the uh closing of the program and put a link on the page.
So if anyone wants additional information or would like to contact you uh for additional information, they just need to click on that link and it'll take them right to your uh website.
Okay, Frank.
Okay, Bill.
Thank you.
Take you take care.
All right, bye now.